I was practically the only non-white
person in my entire high school and you
never felt discriminated again I
definitely did but not because I was
Asian because of your inherent bad
personality exactly
do you remember that internship that I
applied for what about it it's in New
York New York is overrated it's so
gentrified now how many times have you
even been there are we counting layovers
you always assume the worst about me and
then you end up acting crazy over
nothing I'm not acting crazy so stop
using that word
you're just proving my point
are you two like broken up we're taking
some time off while the cat's away the
mouse will play with himself probably
can I kiss you
sorry I'm a little out of practice
it's clear
I'm gonna go to New York listen maybe
you could come with me I thought you
came out here to clear your head I did
and then I met Meredith and I've been
there ever since so when are you gonna
see her I'm here to see Miko she's an
intern here actually I'm the only intern
here
's the problems with anger depression
your weird self-hatred you could benefit
from a little self-hatred
[Music]
interesting
I know you're going to want to blame
this on society or on your race or
whatever but this really is just about
you this is your rock bottom
[Music]
you should do it with that guy you're
being adorable
[Music]
let me just be honest with them
is anyone sitting here
no
[Music]